>> Hi.
I'm Linda Boland Abraham here at Davos.
I've been asked to answer a question what
one thing can governments,
and individuals, and companies do to make
the world a better place.
And, umm, in my view it really comes down
to finding the one thing
that you're passionate about.
Resources and money, of course, are a critical
part of the equation
and we certainly need a lot of the world from
all three of those
groups to step up and provide them but what
really makes it work at
the end of the day in my view is the passion
and the talent that
individuals give in order to make -- make
things happen.
So whether you -- you go into writing, or
organizing, or, uh,
something artistic, everybody has something
special that they're
really good at and really passionate about
and I think taking the
initiative to find an avenue for that and
someone in the world that
could benefit from it.
And I think collectively if you begin to think
about the impact that
that could have, it's really special and that's
the great thing about
Davos is there's so many people doing that
and it's really very, very
inspiring.
So I hope to take some of that home.
Thanks, and hi to all my kids.